no I actually appreciate the human
element part of the game I'm glad we're
not computerized and glad we don't have
instant replay I'm glad our referees
don't have to go look at a computer to
decide if it was in or out i think the
human element provides drama and it
provides conversation you know so if
you're a fan the referee had a terrible
game or he missed a call or you know
that's just part of it and that's those
are the talking points that we need I
mean that's what gets people to the game
and gets them all fired up and get some
invested you know personally into what's
happening on the field and I think I
think as much as I've been on the wrong
end of some calls and feel like I've
been wronged in so many ways you know
that's just part of it and I'm glad it
is that way I'm glad there's some
there's some human human air involved i
think that's I mean to give kind of an
analogy to another sport I think that's
why I appreciate college basketball more
than than NBA because the kids in
college I mean they make more mistakes
and so you can almost relate to them
more and so when there's I don't know
what the pros they never miss baskets
you know the NBA guys and and there's
like they're doing things that most
average people can I feel like with
soccer like I touched upon earlier like
anybody of any shape or size can play
and so they feel like they can do what
we can do and they probably could if
they practice and got fit and you know I
well I don't wanna say it's that easy
but because then it doesn't make me look
like I'm not special and I am I'm
special so uh you know that's I don't
know so that's it I'm leaving it
yeah that yeah I was just a bad decision
on his part I am I feel bad for him
because it tarnishes such a great career
you know just just adds a little dent on
a nice shiny career and it's
disappointing obviously you don't want
that to happen you know in terms of like
kind of the cheap cheap shots I've been
on a lot of ends of that to have broken
my jaw twice and so you know I've been
on the end of some stuff but it's part
of it they could probably cut out that
but I don't know how they can police
that without having more referees on the
field and nobody wants more referees on
the field so you know that's always
going to exist you know the strongest
are going to survive that people can
deal with that still find success